speakers know the order we're going to
start with Julia K 25
Julie I want to start setting up
um all the speakers in this session are
incredibly accomplished but I don't have
a lot of time to tell you about all of
their accomplishments so what I'm going
to do is to briefly just tell you where
they're coming from and what their
interests are and uh what we'll do also
is uh while we are taking question for
one talk I'll ask the next speaker to
come to the front and start setting up
okay so our first speaker is Julia fonte
she is an assistant assistant professor
of ECA at Carnegie Mellon University and
she has a lot of different interests
that are related to our Workshop
including an algorithmic foundations of
blockchains distributed systems
generally privacy preserving uh uh
technology and machine learning and
we're gonna start with her thanks so
much Nika
um yeah so
today I'm going to talk to you about a
distribution-centric perspective on data
selection for Federated learning a lot
of topics that I'm interested about for
this Workshop I decided to focus on this
one
and this was work with a number of
talented collaborators
so when FL was first introduced um so
Katrina gave her a great setup here
whenever was first introduced the
pipeline that people typically talked
about was that we would have this data
from multiple distributed clients and we
would train a model just randomly
initialized and do export the Federated
computation to the client devices
with time our models have been growing
bigger and more complicated and there's
started being benefits to pre-training
these models so for example we might
take a pre-trained model that is trained
on public data like scraped from the
internet
maybe we distill that model to make it
fit on client devices and then we use
that as the initialization for our FL
fine tuning
and the reason for doing this is
primarily one of efficiency and also
model quality so if you can
pre-train your model you require fewer
Federated rounds of training which means
you use up less privacy budget and you
affect the quality of your model less
there's also of course computational
advantages and communication advantages
now in this work we're going to think
about a intermediate step here which
we're going to call pre-fine tuning um
so a number of papers have introduced
this idea by different names but the
idea is that we take our pre-trained
model which was trained on kind of
generic data and we're going to fine
tune it on a still centrally held data
set that is more relevant to our
Federated clients data
so we're trying to push our model in the
direction of the Federated client's data
and again the reason here so that we can
do fewer rounds of Federated training
and of course the pipe dream here is
maybe we can get rid of the Federated
training part altogether
so um
the question here then is how do we
actually choose this pre-fine tuning
data set where does it come from and if
we have multiple options how do we pick
one
so just to give you kind of a quick
illustration let's think about a
scenario where we have test data which
is Federated across multiple clients and
consists of data from stack overflow
uh and on the other hand in our pre-fine
tuning data is some mixture of our real
clients data that stack overflow with
something else in this case Wiki text
and clearly the the best thing we could
do here is to have a pre-fine tuning
data set that matches our test data so
ideally we would like 100 stack overflow
but it turns out you don't actually need
that in order to
reduce the impact of Federated fine
tuning so for example just to put some
so this this table is showing for
different mixtures of our pre-fine
tuning data set
what is our test perplexity uh before I
file fine-tuning and after FL
fine-tuning we want to know how much
that Gap is so just to put some numbers
on this if your pre-fine-tuning data set
is 70 similar to your test data set
FL fine tuning here was giving only a
two percent gain in test
which could be significant in certain
scenarios of course but something to
keep in mind and this table was computed
without DP so once you add the noise of
DP updates during Federated fine tuning
these gains from Federated fine tuning
could get smaller or even disappear
so the key question then is how do we
acquire and find a pre-fined tuning data
set that is good enough that we can
actually reduce how much FL fine tuning
we need to do
and here uh there's been kind of an
explosion over the last couple of years
in
sources of data that people could use
for these purposes and one such source
is data markets so data marketplaces are
places where vendors can put up data
sets sell them and they're easily
searchable by users so AWS has one
snowflake data raid
and on these marketplaces when a vendor
lists a data set so for example here we
see a data set of vessel ownership
I can see that this data set costs seven
thousand dollars to purchase but if but
I can also get a preview a free sample
preview of this data from which I need
to decide if I want to purchase this
data or a different data set from a
different vendor
another example of places where I can
get pre fine-tuning data sets is from
generative data vendors so there's a lot
of companies selling access to
generative models and before I purchase
access to this generative model I'm
typically given a preview of some
samples from that distribution and from
that preview I need to decide whether I
want to purchase access to the full data
distribution
so these are two examples where
basically we have a different options
for data and we're given a small sample
data set from which we need to decide
which data provider we want to go with
so the question the natural question is
how should a data user pick between
these data sets
we started looking at this question in
the following problem setting so we
modeled this uh having end data vendors
each of whom has data drawn from a
distribution P1 through pi
and these distributions can be different
in general we assume these are
heterogeneous distributions
and each of these distributions we can
think of as having some inherent value
to the end user which we'll call Epsilon
of P
but this inherent value of the
distribution isn't accessible to the
data user instead what they see is a
sample data set that's drawn from this
underlying distribution
so for now let's assume that those draws
are independent or IID from the actual
data distribution of course in practice
this could be done adversarially
so we have these sample data sets and
from these data sets we're going to
extract some data set valuation new and
that is what the data user is going to
use to choose which vendor they want to
purchase from
so the Q the core question here is how
do we choose a distribution valuation
function uh Epsilon and the data set
valuation new so that a data user can
identify the best distribution with the
highest Epsilon from samples from the
new of d
now this problem as stated isn't well
defined the course that we need to
determine how to define this Epsilon
without knowing the downstream task so
to handle this issue we use a Huber
model of data heterogeneity
where we assume access to or we assume
that there exists a reference
distribution P star so you can think of
this as like the the test distribution
that the client is trying to match
and basically each data provider has
some contamination distribution q1
through qn
and the actual distribution that they
observe and that they draw their data
from is going to be some mixture of
their contamination distribution and the
true reference
and different vendors can have different
mixtures
and the this reference gives us some
point of reference with which to
determine the quality of a particular
distribution so basically the closer to
the reference you are the more valuable
your distributions
um so the short version of this work
which is still in progress
um is that if you use a distance measure
Epsilon
that is based on the negative MMD
maximum mean discrepancy
and you use a known biased estimator of
the MMD for your empirical Nu of D data
set valuation
and you approximate your reference
distribution P star with a union of all
of the other vendors data
then you can get a guarantee that looks
something like the following this is an
informal statement but let's start here
at the bottom
so our buyer wants to know is vendor I
better than vendor J in the distribution
sense by at least some amount row
what they see is the data set valuations
new of d i and new of DJ we see that
those are different by a quantity Delta
now if Delta is at least as big as this
middle equation then you can guarantee
that with high probability
so what is Delta
um so Delta depends on several terms the
first is the desired Gap row
then we have a bias term based on the
estimator a previewed data set sample
size
and a constant that depends only on the
heterogeneity in the problem
and so the point here is that most
vendors actually don't give large enough
preview data sets to use this result
meaningfully
so this tells us something about how to
select data if we don't care about
privacy we also want differential
privacy it gets more complicated
so actually the MMD estimator has a very
high sensitivity so the terms in red
require a lot of noise to be added to
get a DP estimate of MMD
so um in a recent Workshop paper we
looked at using instead the first shade
distance which has a nice closed form
solution for gaussians and allows you to
get low sensitivity
estimates in it in a differentially
private
and we found that this DP for shade
distance gives very good data selection
for pre-fine tuning
so to summarize data set selection is
becoming more important in FL this may
manifest as pre-f fine-tuning
but I think there's a lot of interesting
questions around how do we select
pre-fine-tuning data sets
um so MMD we've seen allows for a
fine-grained data selection based on
heterogeneous data distributions and for
Shea allows for differentially Private
Selection can we get both and downstream
can we potentially remove the need for
FL fine tuning by pre-fine-tuning
intelligently
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much Julia we have time for
like maybe one or two questions at most
are there questions
oh okay then I'll pass the C
I wanted to ask about the evaluation
imagine because uh as far as I could
tell that was kind of for instance the
price on these sites that uh people are
listing but what happens if that is you
know let's say less than honest how do
you actually start to do this in an area
where people are lying about the quality
of their data yeah
um we've started thinking about that a
little bit but um
yeah I think
I think one knob that we have is to
require or expect vendors to provide at
least a certain amount of data okay
that's again assuming that they're only
they're not lying about data that they
actually have but let's say that they're
taking samples from the data that they
actually have accessible and but they're
choosing that adversarially or
strategically
the larger the data set you require them
to provide the harder it is to try to
mimic a target distribution that they're
trying to match
um and I think there are some
interesting questions around both
modeling the adversary there and trying
to figure out
Julia wants more
[Applause]
our next talk is by Kate Donahue Kate as
a PhD student at Cornell and she's
interested in algorithmic approaches so
generally problems with potential of
societal impact in AI this includes
fairness distributed learning and AI
human AI collaboration take it away
thanks so much
um so I'm Kate donkey I'm going
presenting work with my advisor during
Feinberg on incentives and opportunities
and model sharing games
um so I'm going to start out with a
motivating example
um so imagine that I'm some hospital and
I'm trying to build a model to predict
patient outcomes
um so one option I can use is I could
just use my local data my local patient
data and try and build some model based
off of that
um problem is I might not have that much
data locally this might give me
relatively High error so as everybody's
been talking about we could use
Federated learning or some other sort of
Collaborative Learning setup to try and
potentially do better and one sort of
important question is which of these two
options is going to give the hospital
lower error
um and so if data is IID between
hospitals it's sort of a little bit
clearer priority that Federation is
probably going to be better like all
things be equal there's more data
um but as we're talking about like if
the data distributions are not IAD if
there's truly different patient
distributions this isn't as natural
um and so there are a lot of natural
application areas medical we were
thinking about this in early pandemic so
that was extremely relevant for us then
um but a lot of other cases where this
comes up
um and one thing I really want to think
about is this is especially interesting
review federating agents as game
theoretic players and I think this makes
sense the hospital case in the sort of
cross-silo case I think it's also worth
considering in the case of this cross
device case or maybe I can't actually
with my cell phone I can't choose what I
want to do but I think it matters if I
want to right if I'm dissatisfied the
point where I would rather have some
other option or I'd rather not Federate
at all it should be something that we
should care about
and so if data is not IED federating in
this like Grand Coalition of every video
one group might not be optimal local
learning might not be optimal um it
might be that some other Arrangement
like this thing here like some other set
of coalitions of federating players
might be optimal for different Notions
as possible
and the question I'm going to talk about
is how do I reason about strategic
incentives in Mall of sharing games with
non-id data
and so what do I mean by model sharing
games this is a framework John and I
came up with it's a definitely very
simplified model
um but I think it's expressive enough to
get a lot of interesting questions
some features it has are those varying
numbers of samples per agent so N Sub I
like this cute example on the left like
different agents are contributing more
or less data
um there's some concept of annoys the
data and the noise the learning task and
also bias between agents so the average
is similarity between agents and this
will be sort of a critical term that
will influence sort of the stability and
outcomes a lot of settings
we also model varying Federation methods
different Notions of personalization
um and the cost metric I'm going to
consider mostly is the mean squared
error for learning tasks and we get
exact results for linear regression and
mean estimation
so um some high level questions want to
talk through super briefly is which
rendering arrangements are going to be
stable which arrangements are going to
minimize societal cost and which remain
arrangements are going to be fair for
different Notions of fairness
I'll go through these pretty quickly
um so stability
um high level results or we give
conditions where local learning
federating in the grand Coalition or
some other Arrangement entirely might be
stable we mostly consider individual
stability which is basically no player
who wants to join Coalition that would
welcome it
um and also we consider a few other
Notions generally our results depend on
the size of the players how much data
they have as well as this sort of noise
bias parameter I mentioned previously
we consider different models of
personalization vanilla as well as sort
of fine grained which is basically a
more personalized notion allowing
players to sort of very aggressively
adapt their data and as you might expect
more personalization always increases
the sort of stability of the grand
coalition
so stability
um one question you might immediately
think about like how if we're allowing
players to self-arrange into different
coalitions
um is this going to be optimal and if
it's not optimal how far from optimal
will it be
um and this is the next set of questions
we thought about so we looked at sort of
weighted total error as an objective a
pretty standard objective in Federated
learning
um the first thing we showed is that
either local learning or the grand
Coalition could be arbitrarily far from
optimal so you really sort of can't do
something sort of clean and obvious and
get close to Optimal you have to be a
little more sophisticated we showed that
there exists an efficient constructive
algorithm that gets you sort of the
optimal Arrangement that gets you from
any sort of arbitrary arrangement to
something that's optimal and we use
these results to give a price of Anarchy
bound of nine in this in this setup
the last thing you might think about is
um fairness and this one was especially
interesting
um so we were looking at some of these
related papers and saw that there were
sort of at least two natural existing
Notions of fairness in the federal and
learning sphere I mean I think both of
them make sense in different contexts so
returning to this Hospital example
imagine that I'm sort of a historically
underfunded hospital and I don't have
that much data because I don't have that
much money and you might say like okay
it seems fundamentally unfair that I
would have higher error because of this
maybe our notion of fairness is that we
want to compensate for this and give me
error rates that are roughly equal for
everybody I'm federating with makes a
lot of sense there's another notion of
fairness which is proportional
collaborative and maybe in this setting
assume that I don't have that much data
because I've just been lazy and I
haven't been collecting that much data
Maybe I have adequate budget and here
our goal of fairness might be that I
want to sort of
um punish me for this and we want to
have error rates be inversely
proportional to data collected I think
this also makes sense in different
settings and there's been a series of
works that have been trying to achieve
both of these in different settings
in this work we sort of compare each of
these and give results for when they
might be satisfied
and specifically for gadgetarian we show
its height bound on the ratio of Errors
between any two players federating
together for a quite wide range of
federating methods like it holds for a
relatively large set of federating
methods
proportional and collaborative we showed
the story is more specific to the
Federation method and specifically for
the more personalized notion of
federation we show that a variance
always holds and for this vanilla
Federation of a notion of federation it
holds if it's individually rational
which is a kind of fun connection back
to our first paper where you had this
connection between stability and
fairness like if you know that no player
wants to leave for local learning you
automatically get this notion of
fairness satisfied
so there's some ongoing work and things
I've been thinking about
um there's some questions about
stability with differing knowing player
types like suppose I know that I'm a red
Hospital you could have some interesting
questions about incentives like would I
rather Federate with two red hospitals
who are maybe more similar to me or
three blue hospitals or more different
from me and how does this change you
have to have correct beliefs how does
this change the question of stability
and there's also been some interesting
work on competitive agents so far I've
assumed all players are sort of selfish
but not competitive does this change the
notion of the stability I think there's
also interesting questions around llm
content generation like what if the
outcome of this federating learning is
not a model but it's a model that's
going to be used to create more data
does this change my incentives for
participating
um there's been some work that sort of
built on this model sharing games
framework and sort of personalized
collaboration use it to explore
questions around privacy and data
valuations
um there's also been a ton of really
interesting related work in this space
things around sort of um heterogeneous
data around personalization clustering
work where you sort of cluster people
are similar in different questions
around how you do this when people have
sort of different privacy preferences as
well as different data questions for how
you incentivize people to collect more
data and how you incentivize them to be
honest like so far I've assumed people
are sort of honest but what if they're
allowed to lie how do you make sure they
don't lie and questions about different
fairness
um so yeah this is high little summary
thank you guys so much
thank you so much uh questions yeah
um the Notions of fairness that you
talked about first of all really nice
line of work but I one thing I had a
question about with the fairness it
seems like you might also want this to
depend on the quality of like maybe
you've collect a small amount of data
but it's very you know high quality or
something like that is that take into
account in in the current work or would
they be an easy way to to address that
that's a great question so you can sort
of view data quality as similar to data
quantity Where basically if you you
could scale up and down in the air form
we have that sort of immediately
influences your term of quality
um there's a so there's a model that
sort of that's the high level like you
wouldn't get that roughly we have sort
of a more sophisticated way of modeling
that that's actually in part of this
ongoing work where we have a version
that allows for different quality
um yeah so would you board answer
partially answered but more interesting
working on going great question cool
thanks
we have time for one more question
I'll ask one while pregnant is setting
up
um it was really interesting to see that
towards the end you started talking
about uh choosing your collaborative
like the red and blue in general I was
thinking what are your thoughts about
the role of partial information about
your own type and other types and
attitude towards collaboration
that's a great question
uh no that's a great question
um
so I think that's the thing that sort of
tripped us or the question that was um
worth thinking about where it's like I
need to know my own type I need to sort
of had accurate information about this
and something that sort of was tricky
for a while to think about is like if I
know my own type and I know you're
you're the person's type why don't I
just subtract off the difference and
then we're not in the question of
different data and so you need to be in
this particular data set this situation
where like I know your type but I can't
exactly compensate for that which I
think does exist in some settings
um but it's sort of an interesting set
of things to think about a set of
circumstances did that address your
question or were there more things
um I think this is like we should this
is yeah yeah no definitely sweet okay
thank you so much Kate
um
thank you
okay so our next speaker is Sai pranit
karimarady
um uh praneeth is a postdoc at UC
Berkeley and he got his PhD from epfl he
is interested in his research and I feel
like all aspects of the infrastructure
for Collaborative Learning from uh the
generation of data to the usage of it to
the governance of it so um we're looking
forward to data thank you so much for
the invitation
um so this is going to be a more of an
overview kind of a thing thankfully a
lot of the speakers before have set up a
lot of the things for this so I can be
super high level I'm hoping to spark
more discussion so it'll be a little
light on the technical details okay so
the main takeaway I would hope you guys
to have from this is if you want to
think about incentives in Federate
learning or uh if you want to think
about data markets and these kind of
questions uh experiment design is
probably where you want to look it
offers like a lot of tools from
statistics to think about these kind of
questions so hopefully I'll convince you
of this and the rest
okay uh so what do I mean by a data
market I I really think we should think
of Federate learning as a data market uh
by this I mean that there's a platform
designer who designs the platform to
achieve some goals and that there are we
should really think of the uh as Kate
was saying we should think of the
participants the data contributors the
really as agents who have some agency
uh so this don't the figure doesn't
matter too much but uh the one thing
which changes from the standard
Federated and learning setup where
people just upload the data and get a
model the one thing we change is we
allow the participants to have autonomy
so uh this is this is a rapid uh pointed
out by Katrina that uh so we really need
to give the agents autonomy to decide on
what data to collect what data to share
into the system so what would a system
which allows this look like
uh from from the perspective of the
agent or the system uh what what are the
agents goals so potentially they have a
question they won't answer that's the
whole reason they're participating in
the system this can be a prediction task
right
and they have some payment they use so
this can either be a cache which is like
a standard Marketplace but it can also
they can also pay with their own efforts
with their own data collection
and in return they buy a reduction in
uncertainty on their answer this is the
fundamental transaction which is going
on so you pay either with cash or with
your own data and you buy a reduction in
uncertainty so this fundamentally places
uncertainty and quantification of
uncertainty at like the central role in
all of this
uh just to formalize this setup a little
bit uh
so Suppose there are three agents so I
am on the left and uh I'm trying to see
uh so I have some data set uh so I I
also have a question which is prediction
on this X test
I send my I give my payment which is
this my data set and return through some
magic of Federated learning I get a
model trained and with this model I get
my predictions so what's this uh how
useful was the was this entire process
for me uh to uh to be able to quantify
this we need to somehow measure the
quality of these predictions so you an
obvious way may be okay we can just use
some held out test data to estimate this
quality and to estimate this uncertainty
let's put a pin in that so first of all
we might not have label test data but
okay suppose we do but and we can use
this let's put a pin in like using using
test data to estimate this uncertainty
for now
how does the data market look from a
platform perspective from the
the platform designer wants to attract a
lot of participants
they want efficiency they want to make
most use of the data which has been
collected on the platform
and they want to collect loads of useful
data so this is probably the goals of
maybe they have some more but they
essentially want to shape the decisions
made by the agent so that's the goal of
the platform so these decisions can be
uh so what are the uh the agents can try
to decide is it worth it so I gained
some reduction in my uncertainty but I
have a cost which I have to pay is it
worth it on the whole so this is a
decision which the agent makes so this
is called individual rationality in the
literature another decision the agent
can make is uh if I it's a it's a now a
Marketplace so if I have to maximize
what I'm getting uh if I've
strategically collect decide what data
to collect uh
uh what should I what data should I
collect to maximize my reward
now so clearly to answer any of these
questions we would need to quantify
uncertainty uh we would need a way to
estimate uncertainty to make any of
these decisions
and that's now let's get back to that
pin where we said let's use test data to
estimate this uncertainty
the issue is uh we it it we cannot and
the issue is that any estimate we come
up with with this test data set uh will
influence the agent's decisions so you
have this setting where you you're using
the test data creating some uncertainty
estimates but these estimates are then
influencing the decisions made by the
agent and so are influencing the data
set collected so this is like a classic
problem and statistics that this
inference after data selection uh so you
the estimate is no longer valid so any
kind of uh uncertain estimate which
relies on test data is not useful so
this is like a fundamental problem I
think this is the problem in
figuring out all of these data
marketplaces or incentives and uh so
what's what's the solution
okay first first let's start with
something extremely simple let's just
assume uh data is IID
so then we can just use standard
generalization bonds we have a lot of
theory and generalization works so we
can just use that to estimate
uncertainty and then more data just
means lower uncertainty and it's a it's
a neat clean solution so we started some
we did some initial preliminary work on
trying on like exploring just the
setting and the setting itself has some
pretty interesting results uh so what we
were able to show is that if you model
all of these properly
uh the standard Federated learning
framework suffers catastrophic free
riding
but there is a simple fix to it like or
this kind of the kind of solutions which
gate related to where you Pro you shape
the
the reward which is given is
proportional to the effort you put in if
you do something like that you can
prevent free writing you can ensure
efficiency and you can prove that it is
optimal which means that the most
maximum amount of data is collected by
the by the platform
there's more results which I won't get
into
but this is severely limiting the idea
that you have to assume IOD and the idea
that you have to rely on these loose
generalization bounds to do anything is
pretty limiting
so we were thinking about how to go
beyond this and we see the concrete use
case we were thinking about is uh
clinical trials which are done across
multiple hospitals
so in in such a setting uh you have say
x here represents some demographics
about the patient the Theta star
represents the whatever ground truth
efficacy of the drug you're testing and
the Y reference the outcomes and usually
you assume that it's a linear model
so inside a setting Suppose there are
multiple possible patients you could
recruit into your trial these patients
are spread across the country so across
there's different demographics in this
each agent is a hospital which is
geographically located in some area so
they care only about a subset of these
demographics which is most pertinent to
them so each agent only has access to a
subset and only cares about a subset
so the each agent so each hospital will
autonom will on their own choose which
data which patients to recruit so which
data sets to collect how many to collect
and what to share so they are making the
decisions based on their own uh
best interests
so the in such a framework
so we look at this framework but we
restrict ourselves to this linear linear
setting
the nice thing about this linear setting
is that you can quantify uncertainty
very very concretely so suppose I have
some training data X say say these TR
representative training data uh the
uncertainty along a new Direction X has
this nice close form solution which I
can write down this does not read any
sort of assumptions on what my training
data is and it does not need any
assumption on how the test point x
relates to the training data this comes
from a standard experiment design stuff
uh so and it does not even require
labels training labels to compute this
so we can use this fundamentally we use
this uh which is a basically experiment
design framework to design a mechanism
around it you can create a market around
it
so there's some uh results we have I
won't go again go into the details but
the upshot is that there's many
different criterias people use in
statistics for this uh for for doing
this experiment design we show that only
one of them is actually uh incentive
compatible so this this has pretty
strong implications for running Fair
clinical trials and also that if you so
there's a fundamental trade-off between
efficiency and fairness if you want if
you want to prioritize efficiency you
have to sacrifice fairness so we showed
this dichotomy
so if you care about efficiency there's
a nice algorithm which works and if you
care about fairness or you care about uh
this optimality in terms of maximizing
the quantity and the diversity of data
collected there's also a mechanism which
achieves that
again more results in the paper this is
just like a simple plot to show that
this actually works uh the dark ones and
the top are the baselines and the light
ones at the bottom are so this is like a
huge difference in this
um yeah so also talk to me about uh just
wrapping up now uh also talk to me about
applications uh a lot of these questions
really came from uh talking to uh people
in the applied Fork like uh and ngos who
really grapple with these privacy and
autonomy questions
algorithms and mechanisms like what
Katrina was asking before like this
Collective data governance
thank you
[Music]
thank you so much for the talk we have
time for one short question while
Zachary
thanks so here you focused on the agent
wanting to get something out of the
interaction and I'm curious though in
the other direction maybe it's the the
server that's once or the the
controlling entity one student is what
the agent maybe wants to get is just you
know money or some other form of uh you
know site payment
um does that I'm just wondering how that
uh fits absolutely uh it's not just so
the agents have autonomy they have goals
but of course the principal also has
goals the principal wants to maximize
the amount of data collected maybe they
want to maximize the amount of money
collected uh so this framework captures
it requires both
I guess I'm more thinking of like the
the
um where the agents does not you know so
here the motivation for the agent was
actually improving their predictions but
I think of the setting where the agent
actually doesn't gain anything from uh
or you know not significant whereas and
so
um the principal might make a site
payment to make uh in order to satisfy
uh that's an excellent question uh I
haven't solved on that worked on that
version of the problem but I'm pretty
sure most of the technical stuff here
can be translated
okay uh thanks again for
our next speaker
Zachary Charles
he's a research scientist at Google and
he's of course worked on Federated and
Collaborative Learning and distributed
learning with a special focus on
efficiency and practicality of their
methods
okay great uh how much time do I have
can I take the full 10 minutes or should
I
okay okay cool I'll try to be a little
bit fast though uh this is called
towards federal Foundation models and
this is really envisioning what would it
take to get to a point where we could
actually train Foundation models and
llms using Federated learning and
specifically how do we enable the
research that would be necessary for
that so there's kind of multiple stages
and we're kind of at stage zero
uh this is Joint work with a bunch of my
great colleagues one of which is in the
audience over there Krishna
um
so I don't have to dwell on this um
people have already made this
distinction there's kind of Federated
data where you have uh the data is
coupled to the device it's in or maybe
The Silo that it's in and there's kind
of group structured or collaborative
data which is just that the data has
some notion of partition the data is
grouped according to something and this
encompasses a lot of things like better
learning metal learning personalization
user level privacy and a bunch of other
things so I'm going to de-emphasize data
location and just focus on the group
structure of the data
so why might we want research on llms
and FL
um a really non-exhaustive list I bet
you come up with a bunch of other things
if you wanted one is user level privacy
this is to me one of the most important
uh Ethel is basically one of the most
promising ways to enable user level
privacy uh right now
um there are other Alternatives and I
think they're worth considering but
there's been a lot of traction in terms
of user level VP that you know we should
imagine and we should imagine what would
it take to have for instance Foundation
model that had user level DP baked in
from the beginning
um FL training might improve Downstream
applications if we want personalized
llms why don't we train on relevant data
instead of some random pre-training
Corpus that has no bearing on what
you're actually trying to do
um llm stuff already exhibits group
structure two right all these benchmarks
are group structured data they have 20
different tasks and they evaluate on
each m
and why does our training ignore this
largely it there is some stuff that that
kind of encompasses this but it's not
really one-to-one so uh to me it's very
very exciting to think about how should
we actually do llms with group
structured data
um what do we need for this kind of
research
so the point I want to make is that
Foundation models were essentially
enabled by a combination of research and
engineering and that I don't think you
can divorce the two they really really
reinforced one another and this is a
bunch of papers that really combined all
of these
um it was also aided by the curation of
really large scale data sets
um this I think is a thornier section I
want to maybe say that there are issues
with things like data consent and
copyright and a bunch of other things
and so uh
I think we want something like this to
enable you know work on let's say
Collaborative Learning and llms
um but we both have to take inspiration
from and maybe some critical lessons
from these kinds of work and what did
they do well what did they not do well
how do we adapt it to the settings that
we actually care about so I'm gonna put
that as like kind of a big caveat
um yeah
so what do we actually need for research
on LMS NFL um these are my personal
opinions
um they don't necessarily reflect uh
everybody in this audience
um and I think that you should push back
uh if you feel that they aren't you know
uh true but one of the things that I
really really care about
um research in FL right now uh the
number one complaint that I hear from
people is that there just are not a lot
of relevant data sets that people can
use this is kind of part of federal
learning right the data doesn't leave
the device so nobody has the data to
make available for research so this is
kind of a quagmire and one of the things
I really want to maybe say well I have a
Podium here is that emness and sci-fi
can only go so far so yeah
um we want explorations of how FL works
at larger data set and model scales
small models and large models behave
differently there's a lot of work
showing this and so maybe this is a
question for the audience is client
drives still a relevant phenomenon at
llm scale I'm not actually sure
um we want FL work that prioritizes
research and Engineering
um
I think you need both and doing them
separately just encourages Divergence
uh and also more collaboration and
coordination
um our collaboration should probably
mirror the ethos of federal learning and
when you look at some of the work on
these two slides they tend to be
dominated by single institutions and so
maybe that's a bug in the system maybe
if we actually care about things like
learning across collaborative sources
our research should reflect that
um I am just as guilty of that as
anybody else so I will say that I'm a
hypocrite up here but um yeah
okay
um some work that we've actually been
doing that are two very very very small
steps towards this
um essentially two things one is an open
source Library we're calling data set
grouper
um this essentially to help Remedy or at
least mitigate the issue of making data
that is relevant for FL research
available to academics and Industry
researchers
um it's essentially a way to create
scalable uh group structure data sets
that you can use in your simulations
um it's on GitHub right now open source
um please file issues bugs I monitor it
so I'm very very excited about this I'll
talk a little bit more about what it
does
um and in that and in a forthcoming
paper we actually have some FL
simulations at the scale of gpt2 which
were enabled by this data set Library
so uh data set grouper is intended to be
kind of a flexible way to partition
existing data sets so grab your favorite
data set from let's say tensorflow data
sets or hugging face
um say how you want to partition it
across clients and just go
um it's supposed to be scalable
um there's a caveat there which is
compute that's the always a compute the
caveat but regardless we're able to use
it to get kind of new large scale
Federated Text data sets there are
especially orders of magnitude larger
than other data sets in the literature
in particular we have a Federated
version of the C4 data set which has 15
million groups in it and billions of
words and this is what we use for our
simulations
uh it is platform agnostic it'll work
with anything that uses tensorflow
pytorch jacks or numpy this is a part
where I I see this as really important
and the uh simulation ecosystem in FL
right now is very fragmented and that's
unfortunate
so um this is just some statistics of
kind of ways in which these data sets
are larger than previous data sets
um may or may not be useful to you
um but with this we were able to do kind
of larger scale FL simulations still not
large scale still not like billions of
parameters or anything like that but we
were able to train a 108 million
parameter transform model on Thunderhead
C4 from scratch uh we did 308 averaging
for SGD 16 clients per round 64 batches
per client which is a really really
relevant number
um because it means you're doing lots
and lots of local training at every
communication round uh we did two kind
of evaluation mechanisms we took clients
from the FED book Corpus open data set
which is different from Federated C4 so
it's kind of slight distribution shift
uh we measured the pre-personalization
performance and post personalization
performance so how well did you just do
with the global model and how well did
you do after local training
and we found the results somewhat
surprising
um maybe some in the audience already
has an explanation for this I know there
has been some theoretical work in terms
of let's say two layer models or linear
models or things like that
um but Federated averaging did not do
well in a pre-personalization sense it
acted more as a meta learning method it
essentially was able to adjust more
quickly to these new distributions as
opposed to learning a model that did
well across all clients
um unfortunately timing didn't work out
the full paper is going to be archived
tomorrow if you're interested if you
want to check it out today let me know
I'll send you a preprint
um but yeah so with that
um this is only the tiniest step there's
a lot of things that we need
um we need practical training strategies
group level DP at scale group level fine
tuning what does that look like
um group level reinforcement learning
with human feedback
scaling laws architecture development
fairness and ethics studies benchmarking
like all these things are really really
important to enter essentially uh absent
so I'm interested in them if you are too
please reach out
okay
thank you so much for the talk we have
time for one maybe two questions
um so first of all I really like the
focus on groups I think it like I think
took afino's Point earlier it points out
that in Federated learning this idea of
heterogeneity goes Way Beyond Federal
learning in fact um and so I can imagine
this being very useful for any time
you're trying to learn over
heterogeneous data that the thing that I
was curious about though is
um it seems like with group structured
data part of it would be
you know it'd be important to think
about how the data is being generated in
these different groups so do you have
ways when you have these tools for
partitioning the data how are you
thinking about heterogeneity as part of
that like is it you know are you
randomly partitioning are you trying to
do some sort of you know different
sampling scheme or how have you guys
thought about that so there's lots of
things you can do we've only scratched
the surface
um you could do randomly partitioning we
didn't actually do that we did something
with T4 where we uh every example in it
has an Associated URL you can extract
the base domain from that and we use
that as our partition function this is
arguable as to whether it's useful or
not but it did form some semblance of
groups that was to me interesting at
least
um I have a lot of questions about this
too though
so I have another question uh what type
of devices do you think you're going to
train these things on
I think this is a good question and one
that I don't have the answer to a lot of
people a lot of people are working on
putting Foundation models on device
right now and I don't know what the
progress is going to be in three years
that's where my mind is at you know in
three years or in five years what are we
gonna be able to do on device and let's
anticipate it and meet them there
instead of reacting to it so I don't
have a great answer for you
um and this is part of the reason I
really really like the emphasis on the
Collaborative Learning group structured
learning that's kind of pervaded a lot
of the other talks today
okay thank you so much for the talk
let's thank all the speakers in the
session again
we're gonna take a short break but
before we do that uh Virginia has an
announced oh yeah so uh I think maybe we
can come back at 11 20 so that'll be
about
the full 15 minutes that we were hoping
for but 12-ish minutes
um so a little time for a break we also
wanted to just uh I think there's not
too many additional folks beyond the
invited participants so if folks want to
stay around for the discussion session
that's happening with there's two
discussion sessions that are happening
today please feel free to to do so so
we'd be happy to you know expand it to
this a slightly larger group of folks
that are here today
um yeah so that's all so let's plan to
meet back at 11 20.
um folks who want to stay for the first
discussion session
um so this discussion session by the way
there's a few key topics that I'm hoping
we can can talk about today this is uh
partially just as a way to you know
spark some discussion but also for this
very concrete goal of writing a white
paper that talks about some open
theoretical directions and Federated and
Collaborative Learning so the the first
sort of discussion topic that I want to
talk about and I thought we you know
could talk about for this first session
is basically what are the major
directions we'd want to talk about about
in the space of Federated and
Collaborative Learning the major open
directions and this is useful both as a
way of starting the discussion about
what we mean by these broad terms and
the field generally but it's also
concretely very useful because they will
be sections of the eventual paper and
they'll form the working groups that we
can can join tomorrow so
um I have a couple more thoughts on that
that I'll you know introduce at the
beginning of the discussion session but
let's let's take a break
um so we can come back in 10-ish minutes
at 11 20.